könig der löwen von jon favreau ist eine
einzige große überwältigung maschine die
zum einen den spagat versucht zwischen
diesen königs drama das wir alle seit 25
jahren kennen und der tier doku weil es
eben von jon favreau 25 jahre nach dem
trickfilm original von disney mit natur
realistisch computeranimierten techniken
nachgebaute nachgestellt worden ist die
welt ist ungerecht
nichts war mein kleiner freund
während die einen in saus und braus
leben
führen die anderen ein schatten dasein
tatsächlich überwältigender film ein
film dem aber auf beiden seiten auch was
fehlt weil er zum einen versucht die
tiere in den grenzen des glaubwürdigen
zu halten das heißt diese ganzen
klassierung die das ganze überdrehte
dass wir von zeichentrickfilmen disneys
kennen das bleibt dann aus auf der
anderen seite hat es natürlich dann in
den dialogen die übertreten moment
[Musik]
kuna matata
für diesen ist das natürlich sozusagen
eine neue möglichkeit mit einem stoffen
nochmal auf den markt zurückzukehren und
dass sie sich jetzt einen nach dem
anderen die krieg filmklassiker
vorknöpfen verfolgen wir auch seit
jahren ich glaube jon favreaus erster
dschungelbuch ist jetzt inzwischen drei
jahre her und eigentlich war klar das
bin ich ja löwen folgen müsste folgen
würde
und es war genauso klar dass es eben
einzig darum geht zu zeigen also was
kann man mit den möglichkeiten der
computer animationen heute in einem film
in dem tatsächlich nie tiere vorkommen
kein muslim er kein anderer mensch
werden was kann man da schaffen
alles was du siehst lebt in einem
empfindlichen gleichgewicht zusammen
braucht man das schwierige frage ich
schätze die klassiker und ich schätze
dieses dieses eigentlich filmisch diesen
film sehr ergiebigen widerspruch dass
man zum einen durch das gezeichnet und
durch das leicht überzeichneten figuren
emotional sehr nahe kommt und auf der
anderen seite durch das übertriebene das
satirische die karikatur dann auch auf
distanz gehalten wird dazu das heißt bei
den trickfilmen hat man nie das gefühl
dass man ein tier doku beiwohnt bei der
dann gleich david attenborough der
berühmte tier firma aus dem off sagt
oder predator approaches to pray oder
sowas
[Musik]
wenn man heute das original sieht dann
ist man ihnen sehr genau an das ist für
unsere sicherheit
insofern ist dieser film alt geworden
und sie haben ihn nicht nur visuell mit
dieser natur realistischen
computeranimationen auf die höhe der
zeit gebracht sondern haben auch die
alten songs von elton john
aufpoliert da ist es noch mal drüber
gegangen und haben einen neuen song
spirit von bse hinzugefügte also da ist
schon viel dafür getan worden dass er
mit dem erfahrungen sie gewohnheiten
kinder von heute mithalten kann
auch wenn ich glaube dass 56 78 jährige
in dem film eigentlich noch nichts
verloren haben weil der wirklich königs
mord brudermord schuld kampf und so
weiter eine motiv kette zeigt die in
realistischer darstellung ganz schön was
hat diese schlucht suchen alle löwen auf
um ihr geprägt zu finden
sogar mein vater sogar mufasa kam in
deinem alter hierher rührte sich nicht
vom fleck bis sein gebrüll über den rand
hinaus zu hören war
bis da oben hoch dann weißt du hast es
gefunden mit ein wenig übung wenn dich
niemand mehr ein löwen junges wir fühlen
uns als erfolg konzipiert oder wird
erfolgreich sein und er wird einen
familienfilm sein in denen auch jede
menge jüngere kinder kommen die nach mit
einigen fragen wieder rauskommen werden
darauf sollte man vorbereitet sein
vielleicht kann man die kinder auch
darauf vorbereiten diesen film zu gehen
wenn man schon bedienen eingehen will
es ist ein es ist ein toller große an
überwältigender film
er hat genug action elemente und hart
genug faszination der elemente um viele
leute die ich weiß nicht was anderthalb
zwei stunden die der kinofilm geht zu
unterhalten gesehen haben muss man ihn
nicht
[Musik]